the Joe Rogan experience it's been a
while it's been ten years no more than
that really 2007 I moved out of LA Wow
damn that's weird and talked about you
in the podcast several times though you
know what I never listened to the
podcast until recently someone told in
the second time you said so I think
three times you've mentioned me probably
yoga Rey yoga all these kids are contact
me they mentioned y'all go right on the
show yeah it was cool I appreciate it I
appreciate you I appreciate ya and I
always thought truthfully I always
thought Joe Rogan's gonna do something
good I honestly I can tell you that and
it may be embarrassing to say but and
what I'm proud of you oh he's done thank
you that's very nice that's a funny
thing to say though and you've had great
just Joe Rogan time you had done some
great stuff first of all stand-up
comedian that's that's a great gig it's
fun gig it's a great gig and if I could
pick a second thing besides stand-up
comedian it'd be the announcer I
wouldn't want to be in the UFC even if I
was good because you get pounded on it's
a tough job right yeah that's why you
know what the thailand's see those kids
fight they're retired at 21 yeah did you
beat up they could beat up the three
announcer of the UFC and you're also
skilled at the stuff most people think
the announcers aren't so skilled
sometimes you're very skilled I just
remember rolling around with you yeah
those were some of the greatest memories
of my time in LA is when Annie opened
10th planet yeah we had a lot of fun man
I mean it was such a special interesting
time of Jujitsu I think that it was
going to no noogie there's a demographic
of jujitsu guys who didn't want to wear
a key anymore
yeah what was a lot of people wanted to
learn things that would transition
directly into MMA and to not have the
clothes to grab on to it changed the
grips and Eddie was one of the very
first to really truly concentrate on
using wrestling grips gable grips over
unders things along those lines and then
the other people were still really
clinging to the gay
he was like a and I think the thing that
I was a try
- about the Ultimate Fighting when I
first saw I think the first one I saw
was - you know you have C - and I was
like oh man this is and you watched
those Gracie in action videos and like
yeah this is real stuff real stuff yeah
and so I started even noticing in my
game I just played open guard and I was
lackadaisical and I'd always have to
tell the guys hey do me a favor just try
to slap me because this is getting a
little unreal I don't wanna I want a
real life situation right and I'm
figuring okay I don't want to get by the
way I don't want to get caught up in the
guinot geetha right now but I always
felt like you know real practical
fighting I'm the guy may not be wearing
a tuxedo I think both are good because
like you live in New York New York gets
cold if you get into a scuffle with
someone I hope you never would do but if
you did and he was wearing a jacket like
yours you could manipulate him with that
jacket and they really probably wouldn't
know what to do yeah you know this is a
real benefit to like being a judo player
if someone has a winter coat on yeah
like if you had a fight with Karo
Parisyan or Ronda Rousey or someone like
that and they they're wearing a winter
coat they'll [ __ ] you up you know they
just grab that thing yeah okay yes yeah
well I'm glad I learned that way yeah
it's good way to learn it's good it's
good for defense too because the guy
keeps you from just yanking out of stuff
and exploding out of things you have to
be very patient you have to be if to use
correct technique anyway it was
appreciation and it was one of my
biggest lamentations of moving away was
not to be around that whole posse and
then I never expected it to get as big
as it did
I know it's unbelievable because back
then it was like the seed I used to
bring my my big kids who were big now I
used to bring them and they used to just
box we used to do it at Legends known
before legends Oh
bomb squad that the bomb squad wow
that's crazy that's old-school
yeah that's 2000 what - somewhere else
yeah it was cool it was I just got my
purple was super excited and then Eddie
just got his black you guys brown his
black super quick
yeah well that got his brown and then he
beat Hoyle er and then he got his black
yeah I was there that day yeah that was
crazy
jean-jacques took it off his back
unbelievable
that was heavy yeah it was a good place
to be a good time it was it's like when
you look back at those times it's in it
was an interesting era it was an
interesting error for us as humans it
was an interesting era for martial arts
there's a lot going on and that 10th
planet was really a hub of exciting
innovation and still is but it mean back
then it was this really unique thing
this this completely nogi branch of
jiu-jitsu that's directly connected to
John Jacques Machado which is a totally
re conservative legit mmm judge Aquos is
you know I was always impressed with him
- he still rolls man he's my age and he
doesn't get injured like he might have
like a little tweak here and there but
he's so intelligent and he's so
technical and he's just so good that was
I'm saying was only because I'm not
there anymore but when I was going there
I was like this is such an amazing place
Jean Jacques Academy the quality of
fighters you would get there yeah I mean
that was also at a time where there was
no jiu-jitsu in America I mean was you
have to travel yeah jujitsu school get
the [ __ ] you have to be into it and go
somewhere and to have that many black
belts at a school mm-hmm that was like
unheard of it was in his class one day
there was like 11 black belts I was like
this is crazy and it wasn't like that no
there's a random rogue black belt
somewhere and say you know somewhere in
Portland or something like that you had
to find him it was a lot of purple belts
teaching schools and blue belts teaching
schools in some places even that was a
great time to getting jiu-jitsu oh yeah
like I went I started with hens Oh in
New York yeah I went there the day that
I'm Matt Serra got his purple belt wow
that's crazy it's not crazy it was it is
it was that was such a cool interesting
time would you Jitsu that place is still
the top place in the world it's pretty
impressive and it was such a great guy -
he's the best he's so nice week I gave
him a CD of my band just as a gift I
just met him and he gave me a krugen gay
wow yeah that's
jet was super legit cousins was the the
ghee but that was the ghee yeah if you
had a crew goons like you know it was a
fair trade I wasn't a trade I just
wanted to give him a gift and he just
like without thinking just through the
back at me he had a great attitude well
he still does
he's so loved that guy said I mean
that's one of the really nice things
about jiu-jitsu is the camaraderie and
the friendship it's like it's very
different than I was it's compared to
other martial arts and that the problem
with striking martial arts is that you
hurt each other all the time
you never developed a sort of closeness
that you do with jujitsu because you're
always trying to kick each other's
[ __ ] heads off
[Applause]